KAMENA KOSTOVA: My name
is Kamena Kostova.
And I'm originally
from Bulgaria.
And I'm a senior at MIT.
I'm majoring in biology.
And next year, I'm going to UCSF
to do a Ph.D. In biology.
The reason I came
to MIT because I
wanted to do research.
And I knew that the biology
department at MIT is one of
the best departments.
So I actually started applying
for Europe before I came to
the States.
I started working in Professor
Jacks' lab my freshman year.
It was very hard at the
beginning because I didn't
have experience.
And probably my English
was extremely poor.
DAVID FELDSER: Is
that link p21?
Or is that--
KAMENA KOSTOVA: She's working
like link p21, right?
As an undergraduate,
I should be always
supervised by someone.
And it's definitely a good idea
having someone around in
lab when you're working
with chemicals.
DAVID FELDSER: When Kamena came
to our laboratory, we
were interested in
a specific tumor
suppressor gene called p53.
And we were trying to understand
how p53 works in a
prevalent cancer type called
lung adenocarcinoma.
KAMENA KOSTOVA: I enjoy
doing research.
But I also enjoyed the fact
that my research can have
impact on society and other
people's lives.
The goals of the lab is to build
mass models of cancer.
So we're trying to recapitulate
cancer in the mouse.
And use a mouse as the
tool to study cancer.
So what we're interested
in is p53.
And this is a tumor
suppressor gene.
The reason why it's called a
tumor suppressor gene is
because it helps your
body against cancer.
So if a cell decides to become
cancerous and starts dividing
and accumulates mutation, this
gene gets activated and tells
the cell to stop and correct
these mistakes.
When the cells become cancerous,
very often the
cells commit suicide.
They accumulate mistakes and
are about to pass the
threshold of malignancy, and
then they decide to kill
themselves.
Because it's better
for the body if it
loses these bad cells.
I think it's fascinating that
a cell in your pinkie thinks
about the cells in your brain
and what's good for them.
The project that I'm currently
working on is a drug screen.
So I'm looking for small
molecules that can restore the
function of this tumor
suppressor gene in vivo and be
used as the anticancer
therapeutics.
DAVID FELDSER: We are in
an academic setting.
And I think it's important to
train young people who want to
learn how to do science.
And having access to MIT
undergraduates in particular
is a real benefit to carry
out the research.
KAMENA KOSTOVA: By using
microscopy, we can look at
very thin slices of tissues.
We stain for different pathways
different proteins
that get expressed.
We look at different
interaction
between cell types--
look how the tumor progresses
based on the
morphology of the cells.
What I learn here is how to
be a good scientist--
how to ask the right questions,
how to design
experiments, how to look
critically at your data, how
to communicate with your peers,
and by doing research.
And Professor Jacks' lab really
convinced me that I
want to stay in academia.
I really want to be a
biologist and to
be a scientist.